[Music]
et has been by chanting and genocide
from when they first met on the set of
their 2006 dance classic step up we met
on the screen test actually um he had
already had the part it was like a
chemistry test and that was really well
hi I'm Jenna Dewan
we tested other actors when she just
came in it was done it was over like we
we found our lady in January Jenna
shared that screen test with our YouTube
holes we've laughed the whole time and
he's such a doll it's such a great guy
so when it's hi people you just want to
be around did you start a dating during
production their first red carpet
appearance as a couple was the film's
premiere we're having the time of our
lives I mean we got to dance we got to
fall in love it was in 2009 they
exchanged I Do's and when they walked in
2013 Oscar red carpet Jenna was pregnant
with their daughter Everly wait Carlo
glimpse of you rubbing her belly on the
red carpet already last year Channing
joke that their daughter is far from
impressed at having an a-list Hollywood
dad I've never worked so hard to like
make a girl like me and fail please love
me
she's my harshest critic man it's but
it's the best it's it's a really good
humbling experience I can promise you
[Applause]
[Music]